[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
teaching was a lot different when I
started back in 2003 if a student asked
a question I couldn't answer I would
admit that I was stumped and find out in
time for the next class but now
virtually all of the information I need
to answer any question is accessible via
a smartphone which means that all of my
students have access to the information
as well so my function as a professor is
less about providing information and
more about curating it helping students
learn to separate credible from
questionable sources to evaluate
information critically technology has
changed both my job and the skills that
they are developing more and more faster
and faster technology is taking over
what our brains used to have to do for
some of us this is scary
yet most people embrace smartphones on
the internet as extensions of our brains
using them for everything from
fact-checking to maintaining social
relationships without thinking about how
these tools might ultimately affect our
cognitive skills but based on what we've
learned in this course this something we
really ought to think about after all no
matter what it is that you're doing
we've learned that spending a lot of
time engaged in an activity will shape
the wiring of your brain that's both the
brain's pitfall if the activity is
maladaptive like taking addictive drugs
or its greatest potential if we're
talking about mastering chess or the
violin so there's no doubt that the use
of technology like smartphones is
changing our brains the real question is
how is technology making us stupid as we
rely on it more and more warnings that
technology will turn our
to mush we're on the lips of great
thinkers long before Google arrived on
the scene
for example Plato quotes Socrates as
saying the following about the invention
of writing this discovery will create
forgetfulness in the learners souls
because they will not use their memories
they will trust to the external written
characters and not remember of
themselves writing will give your
disciples not truth but only the
semblance of truth they will be hearers
of many things and will have learned
nothing
since Plato's time and especially since
the rise of the Internet we've heard
many more warnings but technology is
making us stupid but is there any truth
to these claims are there any scientific
studies that demonstrate ill effects of
technology on cognitive functions like
attention memory and decision-making
well let's start with what is probably
the most common fear but access to
smartphones is killing our attention
span I've seen headlines claiming that
our attention span is now shorter than
that of a goldfish less than eight or
nine seconds according to a study by the
Microsoft Corporation so what is an
attention span over a hundred years ago
the father of Experimental Psychology
William James said that everyone knows
what attention is but after a century of
studying it
psychologists still can't always agree
on a definition with help ashlar an
eminent researcher of attention quipping
that no one knows what it is but let's
agree that we're talking about how long
we can focus on something do we really
mean that smartphones are killing our
ability to focus or is it that our
tolerance for boredom has decreased what
evidence do we have the same person who
flips through social media quickly not
lasting more than a few seconds on any
given post can't focus their attention
for longer periods of time on another
task well if someone took all the fees
and updates that you might glance that
during
15-minute social media reading session
packaged it into a book and then fold it
would you buy that book probably not but
those same people who are accused of
being addicted to social media who won't
spend more than a few seconds on any
given post can still get lost in the
novel or a movie to back up that idea I
present to you worldwide phenomena like
Game of Thrones Harry Potter and even
the Twilight Saga which captured a
generation of teenagers for whom books
were almost quaint if a kid can spend
hours in front of a media console
playing a video game or reading Harry
Potter does he have a defective
attention span
well you might say we're talking about
two different skills getting lost in
something interesting is not the same as
having to focus on a topic book or paper
that is less about entertainment and
more about education from that
perspective attention span is more a
question of fighting boredom or keeping
oneself actively engaged with the
material at hand rather than relying on
the presenter to hold our focus so what
about the idea that people in the past
were able to tolerate bored and much
better and the smartphones and other
tools have made us less able to control
our own minds was louis xvi content to
sit alone in a corner thinking or did he
require constant lavish entertainment if
Mozart refused to leave his music studio
to attend a dinner party would we say he
lacked attentional resources ah you
might argue but mossad could focus on
his work for hours and I would argue
that most of us can focus on things for
hours it's just that those things that
keep our attention change with each
generation and individual it depends on
what we find entertaining be it musical
composition or comparing vacation photos
doctors offices have had magazines in
them for decades because waiting with
nothing but our minds to occupy us is an
aversive state for many of us
the phenomenon has been around a while
not one that emerged in the internet age
and then there's a study that Donald
Hebb launched in the 1950s when he
planned to have student volunteers
locked away in a room by themselves for
six weeks but solitary confinement is so
painful that no one lasted more than a
week in all of these instances we
confront a basic fact about the way our
brains are wired we get stressed when we
feel as though we aren't in control what
does this have to do with boredom you
might ask well John Eastwood at York
University has proposed that boredom is
a function of feeling that you want to
engage in a satisfying activity but for
some reason you can't and you attribute
that reason to something in the
environment which you can't control the
doctor's waiting room the long flight
the unending lecture these are all
situations in which you don't have
control over the main activity you're
involved with so to regain some control
and to minimize the subversive state
people turn to some diversion maybe it
used to be a magazine or some kind of
gossip now it's a smartphone but the
human tendency is essentially the same
being bored is considered shameful by
many people any of us look down our
noses at people who are easily bored
seeing it as a sign of lack of
intelligence but boredom can actually
lead to creativity as a study from 2014
found in which people who copied phone
numbers out of a directory came up with
more uses for polystyrene cups than
those who didn't engage in a boring task
first the problem now may be that we
have fewer opportunities to learn how to
entertain ourselves using only our minds
with smartphones and tablets the range
and quality of the entertainment at our
fingertips has changed dramatically and
this means that it's easier to assert
control by turning to our devices when
we're feeling bored some would argue
that checking social media doesn't
compare with reading Anna Karenina but
the truth is
that we have that choice the novel is
just as accessible as any other
application or game
why don't we always choose literature
over status updates the answer is of
course different for different people
but for many of us the rewards of
getting lost in a great novel take a bit
longer to reap we can't just read a
sentence or two and reap the benefits
you need time to get lost in the story
and having to interrupt your experience
when the flight lands or the doctor
calls you in can be jarring reminding
you of the fact that you're not in
control of your mental state but
checking out a photo of your niece or
reading a text message from a friend can
fit into any tiny tiny time period
giving you a sense of accomplishment
when you're called away from the
activity rather than reminding you that
you're waiting on someone else
John Eastwood worries that smartphones
have made us less skilled at tackling
boredom putting us on a slippery slope
in which we tolerate it less and less
not having to submit to boredom we don't
learn how to eliminate it using just our
thoughts he has likened it to an
addiction suggesting that the more you
do it the more you feel the need to do
it you might have come across headlines
purporting that checking social media is
addictive that people behave as if
they're on drugs and that the brain
looks like it does when you take cocaine
I can assure you this is an exaggeration
yes the dopamine mediated reward system
can get activated which is where these
comparisons come from but dopamine as
we've learned isn't just a reward
chemical and the regions involved don't
just light up when you're enjoying
yourself it's more like a salience
network activated when something in the
environment is worth paying attention to
now you probably recognize that checking
social media is not as engaging as
getting lost in a great novel and we can
see the difference in how the brain is
activated too but checking social media
can be more rewarding than just waiting
for something to happen and being
interrupted while you're on your phone
might be less aversive and if you were
lost in a novel so you'll see more of
the dope
mean system activated when flipping
through some app then you will if you're
just sitting in the doctor's office
bored but studies are also showing that
instead of the internet making people
more distractible it's likely that
people who were more distractible to
begin with struggle more with the
nefarious aspects of technology use so
far we've been addressing the question
does technology adversely affect our
ability to focus and the short answer
seems to be no rather it's more accurate
to say that the wealth of information
that our fingertips these days gives us
a new way to satisfy one of our brain's
needs the need to avoid boredom and to
feel in control of our attention if we
constantly avoid boredom by going to our
digital devices however we might fail to
learn how to overcome it using the
resources of our brains now let's turn
to a slightly different question does
computer use make you less intelligent
and more reliant on technology well this
may surprise you but some studies have
shown the opposite for example one study
from 2010 showed that people who use
computers more also tend to show better
performance on certain cognitive tests
in this study the authors analyzed data
from thousands of telephone interviews
of adults age 32 to 84 these
participants were asked about their
computer use from never to daily then
they were asked to complete a battery of
tests over the phone designed to assess
certain aspects of cognition these
included things like remembering a list
of words keeping digits in mind
completing a series of numbers using
inductive reasoning and saying as many
words from a category say fruits as you
can in one minute what they found is
that frequent computer use was
associated with better overall cognitive
performance across adulthood even when
they accounted for age education sex and
health but you might argue that
computers are generally used by smarter
people so one would expect frequent use
is to perform better on these tests
simply because they're smarter well even
when the researchers controlled for
intelligence they still found a
correlation between computer use and
what we call executive function
specifically greater speed at switching
between tasks this finding is in line
with other studies that have also found
an association between more frequent
computer use and better cognitive
outcomes and older adults in fact people
who have fewer intellectual and
educational advantages seem to benefit
the most from computer use it's a bit
like malnourished kids and vitamin
supplements which we discussed in our
lecture on brain food in another large
study this time of more than 5,000
Australian men aged 69 to 87 who were
followed over the course of eight years
computer youth was found to be
associated with a thirty to forty
percent lower risk of incident dementia
that is the men who were diagnosed with
dementia once the study was in progress
but not before
how might computer youth benefit the
brains of older adults if you'll forgive
the cliche the answer might be use it or
lose it even a relatively passive
activity like browsing the internet
engages the prefrontal cortex where our
executive functions like reasoning and
decision-making reside but older adults
who are newbies to the internet don't
show this same pattern of activation
they just show engagement of parts of
the brain used in reading so it seems
that with experience Internet use can
change how the brain is engaged during
browsing time is a factor interventions
in which computer use have been used as
the treatment for up to a year have
generally failed to show positive
effects in older adults but over the
course of many years the efforts seem to
pay off what about the idea that Google
and the availability of information in
our fingertips is destroying our ability
to remember if you know that a
particular fact will always be available
to you
via the internet will that knowledge
affect whether or not you remember it
many people complain that knowledge is
skin-deep these days that our memories
are harmed by the fact that we don't
need them as much as we used to have we
made a Faustian bargain with computers
building their memory at the cost of our
own to answer that question
a group of memory researchers had
subjects read trivia statements and then
type them into a program on the computer
half of the subjects were told that what
they typed would be saved and the others
were told that it would be erased then
they were tested on their memory for the
facts that they were asked to learn sure
enough people who thought that what
they've typed would be erased showed the
best recall these findings are in line
with other research demonstrating that
when people think that information will
be available to them by some other means
in the future they don't remember it as
well the effort we make when trying to
learn information plays a big role in
terms of our ability to recall it later
whether the subjects were told that they
would be subsequently tested on the
information however didn't seem to
affect their memory performance it
didn't matter if they were told they
would need the info it only mattered if
they thought they would later have
access to it
but the availability of information via
search engines has made us feel and so
it's unnecessary to remember almost
anything in a sense we seem to be living
in the experimental group who thinks
that they will always be able to find
that information later on so perhaps the
skills that we need are those that
involve learning how to find the
information rather than remembering its
content
sure enough in another experiment
subjects were given statements to read
and then they were told one of three
things either the statements were stored
somewhere in a generic folder on the
computer or that they were stored in a
specific file or that they were erased
again memory for statements that
subjects were told were erased was
better than in either of the other two
conditions but subjects who were told
that the infamy
was stored in a specific file remembered
where to find it later what this means
is that Google is changing how we
remember we are better at remembering
where to find the facts that we are at
remembering the facts themselves but
maybe as the number of facts available
to a skyrockets this skill is actually
more useful to us long-term and this
underscores a point I made frequently in
this course the brain is both malleable
and adaptable as our technological
environment changes our brains develop
different skills that help us meet the
distinctive challenges of the new
environment
but what about the idea that the
proliferation of social media and
smartphones is making us less social
artists have taken to photographing
people and growth in their smartphones
in all types of different situations to
people having which should be a romantic
dinner but both connecting more with
their phones and each other is there any
evidence that social media is
disconnecting us initially people who
spend more time on social media do spend
less time and face-to-face interactions
but even that is changing in 1998 Robert
kraut and his colleagues published a
study of 73 households who had just
gotten access to the Internet and the
study made headlines because it showed
that the more these families used the
Internet the lastic communicated with
each other their social circles declined
and they became more depressed and
lonely the internet was hurting their
social lives crowd called it the
internet paradox but in 2002 kraut and
colleagues published a follow-up study
that didn't generate nearly as much
attention in the press the study titled
internet paradox revisited reported at
three years later the negative effects
of the internet had dissipated in the
original families and in a larger sample
of 406 new computer and television users
using the Internet actually improved
communication social involvement and
Welby
the best results were seen in people who
are naturally outgoing crowdin
colleagues called us the rich get richer
effect they found poorer outcomes for
people who were less social or had less
support and people who are shy tend to
have fewer friends on social media but
contrary to the idea that social media
disconnects a study from 2012 showed
that increasing the number of times a
person posts on Facebook correlates with
feelings of greater connection to their
community and this intervention for
seeing participants to post more
regularly was especially beneficial to
people who are naturally shy social
media gives us new ways to stay in touch
and connect and we learn to adapt our
own online behavior if we find that
these technologies are harming us if
Facebook makes you sad you'll learn to
use it differently or not at all having
online identities does affect how we
think about ourselves in part because we
now have access to much more information
about our past but how different is
storing information online from sharing
memories with a long-term partner one of
the great benefits of spending a life
with someone else is the cozy feeling
that I've forgotten if I forgotten some
details of important life events like my
wedding day or my son's first steps I
got my husband to fill in the missing
information but now I can also just look
through my vast repository of photos
videos text emails and so on my son is
growing up in a world that is very
different from mine in terms of how his
experiences are documented I don't have
a single video of myself before the age
of about 10 my son is not even three and
we already have hundreds of videos and
thousands of images of him growing up
how will all this documentation affect
his memory will he just remember
watching the videos over and over again
or will the cue rich stimuli trigger
actual memories of the events
how will watching his past behavior
shape his future decisions I don't know
the answer to that question
other than to be fairly convinced that
he will be sub leash subtly shaped by
all this documentation at the end of the
day technology is a tool that can
dramatically expand our capacity to
store and retrieve information if you
think of the internet as an extension of
our memory for example then there's no
question that it is a vast improvement
over the capacity of any individual
human brain but some people still balk
at the idea that technology can enhance
certain characteristically human
functions like creativity if you're in
that camp of skeptics I'd like you to
consider the story of alphago back in
1997 the world was shocked when deep
blue an artificial intelligence system
built by IBM beat the reigning world
chess champion Garry Kasparov this event
served as a kind of turning point when
we had to admit that AI was catching up
to human intelligence at least in
specific ways no one today would argue
that you can't build an artificial
intelligence machine that can best any
human in chess so people who believe
that a I can never simulate the human
mind began to point to the ancient
Chinese game of go to demonstrate human
superiority over artificial intelligence
some pointed to go as the last frontier
the last game in which humans could beat
machines the oldest board game still
played today go has been around for
thousands of years it's a two-player
game in which each player places stones
on intersecting lines in a grid without
getting into the rules suffice it to say
that go is considered far more
complicated than chess because of the
number of alternatives for each play
some have said that there are more
possibilities and go than there are
atoms in the visible universe there are
a lot of atoms in the visible universe
so I'm a bit doubtful but the scope of
options and go is unquestionably fast
because searching through algorithms and
stores of data is how
I can easily beat out humans the fact
that go skill doesn't rely on brute
search made it less vulnerable to
machine dominance in a game like chess
it's thought to be the most complex game
ever invented and mastered by our
species the pinnacle of our intelligence
and the one skill that computers
couldn't match until 2016 that's when a
network of hundreds of computers at
Google controlled by the artificial
intelligence named alphago beat the best
go player of the decade we siedel go a
game that arguably requires the best
that human minds have to offer strategy
judgment adaptability beat so is it time
to hang up our hats and give in to the
domination by our computer overlords
lurking just around the corner
wait a minute you might be thinking
wasn't this lecture about how technology
is making us smarter not the other way
around
indeed it is one of the go players who
helped train alphago by playing against
it
Fong Hui has said that the AI made him a
better player showing him possibilities
that he had never seen before we already
know that music algorithms can write or
atleast evaluate pop songs and these
algorithms can even make human composers
more creative giving them access to many
more soundscapes and experiments of
music than would be possible without
them so to sum up technology opens new
frontiers to humans and it's natural for
people to have concerns and even
anxieties about what may happen as we
explore these new frontiers but when it
comes to the question do today's
technologies make us stupid well based
on the evidence we'd have to say no
rather our brains are adapting to the
new skills that technology will demand
of us remembering where to find
information for example in favor of the
facts themselves and with that thought
we've come to the end of our lecture
series we've explored a number of
fascinating topics in
course but to pull it all together let
me leave you with three fundamental
principles that I hope will stay with
you and help you build a scaffold upon
which you can hang new information about
the brain as its discovered and reported
first remember that the brain is not
perfectly designed it's messy random
inefficient full of shortcuts that allow
us to think quickly but also lead us to
make mistakes from the lowest levels of
perception to the highest levels of
decision-making second I hope you've
learned that no brain region is an
island the power of the brain is in its
inner connectedness and the mailee
ability with which it wires and rewires
with experience and finally we've seen
that our thought processes can be
divided into two systems we have a fast
thinking automatic set of processes that
make up what we often call a gut
instinct of which we are largely unaware
and we have a deliberate slow rational
set of processes that we think dominate
our actions more than they likely do
many many of our judgments arise from
our fast thinking system and sometimes
those judgments can have negative
consequences both for individuals and
for society at large but whether we're
talking about racial bias optical
delusions vivid remembering or any other
brain function we can choose to bring
that slow thinking system into play
we're lucky enough to be able to check
our actions choose to act responsibly
and ethically and apologize for our past
mistakes science continues to unravel
the many mysteries of the brain and with
each new discovery the story just gets
more interesting we focused on
dismissing some of the myths that
surround our mental lives but in the
process I hope I've only enriched your
sense of wonder at that amazing and
often baffling thing the human brain and
I hope that you will leave this course
with a better sense of how your own mind
work and how it will continue to change
in the future